los cuatro países se revelan que 14
líderes mundiales se escondieron sus
fortunas para no pagar impuestos según
las investigaciones el presidente
ecuatoriano guillermo lazo es nombrado
en el caso y se lo relaciona con
paraísos fiscales la investigación
también asegura que el actual mandatario
se deshizo de las entidades offshores
antes de asumir la candidatura a la
presidencia las aspiraciones políticas
de guillermo lasso lo llevaron a cambiar
las estructuras de las empresas que
tenía fuera del país según el consorcio
internacional de periodistas de
investigación
el presidente de república habría
aprobado en el año 2017 que las acciones
de activos y entidades de panameñas
relacionadas a él se transfieren a dos
fideicomisos que habían sido creados en
dakota del sur de los eeuu según los
reportajes al ser consultados sobre
estos fideicomisos el presidente
guillermo lasso respondió siempre he
cumplido con la ley ecuatoriana que
prohíbe a candidatos y funcionarios
públicos mantener compañías offshores
tal y como lo he señalado en mis
declaraciones juramentadas es una carta
enviada el 27 de septiembre al consorcio
y el diario ecuatoriano el universo
asegurando no tengo ninguna relación de
propiedad de control beneficio o interés
de ningún tipo estas entidades respondió
el mandatario
la filtración se relaciona con 14
proveedores de servicios de registro y
administración de empresas y
fideicomisos en distintos países
considerados paraísos fiscales hasta la
fecha no se ha producido ninguna
reacción oficial de la presidencia de la
república en ecuador'